well we have a good panel this morning
and the whole Saturday morning is framed
generally around the topic of online
education we're going to hear different
perspectives of it and we're going to
approach it in a very broad manner
actually so we will have very narrowly
defined online education of the sort
that I think Margit will talk about
Hillsdale has done an excellent job with
you'll hear more about that later all
the way to resources that can be
accessed online or multimedia resources
that are outside the normal type of tool
you might use in your classroom so we're
going to cover a broad range of items
today our first panel we have our two
panelists to my left here and the first
one is going to be Kevin Hughes and he's
going to be talking about a multimedia
tool that acting had a little bit to do
with which i'm proud to say the poverty
cure dbd curriculum and i won't steal
his thunder but i do want to thank
Hillsdale because last year and
ultimately I believe Durrell foundation
made available to every faculty member
here a full DVD set of poverty cure and
I know many of you used it so I'm very
happy that it was helpful to you so the
first first up will be Kevin with kind
of a case study of how he implemented
that and what the reaction has been
Kevin is the associate dean for
administration and professor of
management at mount vernon nazarene
university he received his PhD in
organization and management from Capella
University in 2003 and through his
church kevin has traveled two dozen of
dozens of countries building facilities
for orphan orphanages and schools he
speaks widely on international education
topics this sounds like a bull's eye for
you Kevin please join me in welcoming
Kevin Hughes
thank you Chris thank you for this
opportunity this is amazing it was just
a year ago in San Diego I was sitting in
the back row on Saturday morning
listening to Michael Matheson Miller
talking about poverty cure and it's a
it's been a whirlwind of a year since
then but thanks for this opportunity I'm
humbled and and I'm honored to get to
share with you how we've implemented
poverty cure Adam being you in our MBA
programs good teacher should pull an
audience first how many of you have
watched the poverty care DVD series to
thank you how many of you have been able
to implement it in a course in some way
great so hopefully by the end of this
next year the same set of hands will be
raised both times anyway in my role is
associate dean in the gender School of
Business at mount vernon nazarene
university i have general oversight for
the curriculum in our graduate business
programs and includes an mba MSM and an
mba health care administration as a
professor of management with a
specialization in international business
i have the specific responsibility to
manage the curriculum we use in all of
our graduate level global business
courses outside of work I also enjoy
traveling and working overseas i spend
about two weeks each year in developing
countries working alongside some amazing
people who need some assistance in
building schools training sisters
training centers churches and community
centers i first became aware of the
poverty care DVD series when i received
a copy from hillsdale college thanks to
the darrell foundation in preparation
for the 2013 free market forum in san
diego then I had the privilege of
meeting Michael Matheson Miller who was
the only person sitting farther away
from the podium last year that I was
right before that and hearing his
presentation at the free market form the
message of the poverty cure organization
and the DVD series
resonated with me I've worked in many of
the countries depicted in the series and
I counted a rare privilege that come
alongside these hard-working people all
around the globe who are praying for a
hand up and not a handout I counted an
incredible blessing to have a front-row
seat to see what can happen when people
practice the god-ordained principles
presented in this series to unleash the
transformational benefits of true
charity justice and human flourishing I
was convinced that my students needed to
learn these principles too so I
incorporated the poverty cure DVD series
into our graduate level global business
curriculum this course is a required
class for all of our graduate students
and all instructors who teach the course
are required to use the curriculum that
I developed so now all of our graduate
business students are exposed to poverty
cure DVD series before they graduate the
Global Business course is offered in
both a face-to-face and an online format
in both formats it's delivered across
the six-week period and since there's
six episodes in in the DVD series even I
who are not a math genius by any means
realized I could embed one episode each
week in the course I require students to
watch each of those episodes each week
and then react to it in a graded
discussion forum in the forum they
discuss the implications of what they
see in here in poverty cure as it
relates to our other course materials
and as it relates to current
international business and economic
events since we require faith
integration components to be embedded in
each of our courses I challenge students
to view each poverty cure episode
episode through the lens of faith they
ponder how a responsible person of faith
can best work towards a true and lasting
cure for poverty I appreciate how
poverty cure rationally and methodically
makes the case for achieving human
flourishing through a healthy
integration of faith and free market
capitalism my students ranged in age
from there
mid 20s to mid 50s and I love watching
the light bulbs come on for students of
all ages as they watch each episode we
conduct a end of course surveys in all
of our courses and I love reading the
comments from students as they say what
a life-changing and paradigm altering
experience poverty cure has been for
them I think I've had at least one
student in every section I've personally
taught expressed a desire to purchase a
copy of the the DVD series to share with
friends and family thanks to the
assistance and support of people like in
yoakum uncle and mark van der mas we now
have the poverty car DVD series embedded
in our Moodle course template platform
so we can seamlessly use the series and
all face-to-face and online sections of
the course so now even students in our
face-to-face sections where they watch
the videos in class together they still
appreciate that the episodes are
embedded in Moodle our learning platform
if you're not familiar with Moodle so
they can go back and review the episodes
outside of class or refresh and
reinforce their memories as they do
their course assignments here's a couple
email comments about poverty cure from
my MBA students over this past year
first when dr. Hughes I really enjoyed
watching and learning about poverty in a
different light before these video
segments I was always led to believe
that the more we gave the better it
would help those in poverty well after
watching these videos my eyes were open
and I know that more is not always
better I learned that the developing
countries would like the chance to
develop and not just be given handouts
another student wrote hello dr. Hughes I
wanted to drop you a note regarding the
poverty cure video series I think this
is a wonderful addition to the course
especially used in conjunction with the
faith integration it was enlightening to
see that this perspective on poverty and
charity and come out with an
understanding that while well intended
we may not really be helping in fact we
may be hurting I enjoyed it so much i
purchased it so my family and friends
can watch it to thank you for making
this part of the class I hope it will
help people make smarter decisions when
it comes to
working with people in developing
countries here's a few comments from
students on those in the course surveys
where they're speaking completely
anonymously one quote absolutely loved
the poverty cure video series which
provided a perspective that I had not
thought about before another student
wrote the poverty cure video
complemented what we were learning in
both the textbooks the textbooks alone
would not have provided the depth to the
coursework please keep the poverty cure
video series in the class material it
truly is a great take away another
student wrote poverty cure series
poverty cure video series each week was
an excellent way to help me to begin to
think globally and to think from a much
different perspective each segment was
thought provoking and spiritually
challenging and one final quote this is
a brief one quote poverty cure was
fantastic in quote I can honestly say i
believe the addition of the DVD series
to our global business course template
is the single best curricular move I've
made and the 15 years that I've been
managing curriculum at some level or the
other its current its cogent it is
succinct and it resonates with all of my
graduate students it's put a spark in my
course no book or research assignment
ever has before I have personally worked
in on 13 overseas construction project
so far and I have I can attest to the
accuracy accuracy and validity of the
poverty cure message based on my
observations in class and student
feedback the poverty cure DVD series
expresses this message of human
flourishing so much more effectively
than my personal trip videos slideshows
from my trips that I was showing in
classes before that I still work those
into the class but in other places they
have to see the picture i encourage all
business faculty to to visit poverty
cure org that's the website to learn
more about this international network of
organizations and individuals and to
learn more about the DVD series i would
challenge professors in curriculum
developer
to watch the DVD series through the eyes
of their students and then consider if
adding this to your curriculum might not
be one of the best decisions you could
ever make for helping prepare students
to be global contributors to and
champions for human flourishing thank
you Wow Kevin thank you you'd think we
paid him to say all that okay up next is
one of your colleagues dr. Margaret
Britt she's a professor of human
resource management at mount vernon
nazarene before she entered the teaching
profession dr. Britt spent 20 years in
leadership at Digital Equipment
Corporation he spoken at a wide range of
conferences on the subject of online
education and her doctorate in human
resource management is from South
Eastern University in 2002 dr. Britt
good morning I want to thank you for the
opportunity to present I'm really
humbled to be here today I specifically
want to thank Dave Durrell from the
george edward durell foundation i want
to thank a need of folsom the director
of the free market forum and her
advisory board and i'd also like to
thank dr. Mary Kelly from Texas A&M
University in Central Texas two years
ago we did a panel discussion in Myrtle
Beach South Carolina concerning higher
education and Mary really opened my eyes
to the importance of certifications for
this industry in the future so thank you
Mary and I also want to thank Dean
Robert roller our Dean at the jetter
school business from mount vernon
nazarene university for his support of
this conference what I want to talk
about today is online education where
are we and where are we headed there's a
major higher education success story
southern ave southern New Hampshire
University which is a secular private
at school it has nothing to do with the
University of New Hampshire state system
and I will talk about them in a minute
we're going to look at some industry
statistics various types of online
education there's a raging debate today
on the pros and cons of online education
challenges for students challenges for
professors what some of the
accreditation standards are education
and change I want to talk about 1mb a
new online success story Sam no bellucci
who is a first-year medical student this
year and we will discuss him and then
the conclusion so with that let's talk
about southern New Hampshire University
in Manchester New Hampshire you see a
lot of their ads online they are a
secular private nonprofit educational
institution when Paula blank came became
the president in 2003 it was a very
small school their enrollments at that
point were under 2,000 then the
recession hit in 2008 and they were on
the verge of bankruptcy leblanc went and
hired dr. clay Christiansen from Harvard
Business School he is the author of the
innovators dilemma which basically talks
about the concept of disruptive
technology which means that companies at
the bottom of the market use
technologies to eliminate older
competitors and then he collaborated
with Johnson and K gurman in 2008 to
write the book reinventing your business
model and basically in that book all
three men talked about the fact that
when there are disruptive technologies
in the marketplace people do not change
their business model and hence they are
not as successful as they could be so in
2009 probably convinced the board of
trustees at southern New Hampshire
University to basically increase online
education and he hired dr. clay
Christensen
from Harvard on the board of trustees
Khan in 2014 wrote that dr. LeBlanc
solution was to tackle what colleges
were doing poorly graduating students
half of the students who enroll in
post-secondary education accumulate debt
but they never get a degree Khan also
wrote in the same article that public
institutions will not see increasing
state funding and private colleges
cannot see ever rising tuition and we
know his business people that's a true
statement so from 2009 to 2013 in the
space of four years what they did at
southern New Hampshire University was
have standardized online curriculum they
had a tweak undergraduate courses they
hired many admissions counselors and
they had a warning system if students
did not interact online so in the space
of four years their enrollments their
traditional enrollment went up to two
thousand seven hundred and fifty
students and 25,000 students and what
this did at the end of the 2013-2014
academic year was give them 20 29
million dollars in profit of which 22
million has gone to build a new library
seven million has gone to hire 25
full-time professors and the Parthenon
group in Boston calls southern New
Hampshire University one of the most
significant players in the online space
oh they'll let me just say add in
passing Liberty University because
southern New Hampshire University did
this in four years and right now as of
the beginning of this October they're up
to 34,000 online students Liberty
University has over a hundred one
hundred and two thousand students and
they have over 90,000 online they have
Liberty is the largest christian
university in the world they are in the
top ten in the united states for online
they've been extremely successful in
their model but southern New Hampshire
University made significant leaps in
only four years so what about some
industry statistics private colleges
today and many people in this room know
this because we're increased many of us
are in Christian higher ed are facing
declining enrollments from 2010 through
2012 freshman enrollment declined at
many of the private colleges at a rate
of ten percent or more from 2006 through
2009 belkin in the innies Wall Street
Journal analysis of Higher Education
said only one in five experienced that
decline and also there's tremendous
growth in the adult markets and they are
projected to increase by twenty-three
percent by 2019 some in this other
industry statistics and let me just also
say this there's if your school does
online education allen and semen did a
comprehensive 10 year report from 2002
to 2012 it's available online you can
download it it's got some very
interesting information about online
education in this country some of the
statistics thirty-two percent or 6.7
million of all college students
completed one online course in 2012
chief academic officers who believe that
online education is vital is now at
sixty-nine percent and this is a high
for the ten-year period and then the
mass of Oakland line course is commonly
referred to as MOOCs that many of us
have heard in this room two-point-six
percent of all colleges use this while
nine point four percent of all
institutions plan to use them however it
is your doctoral land research programs
that plan to use them at a much higher
rate of two
one point four percent let me also add
that the Allen and seaman report they
surveyed eighty-three percent of all
higher education enrollments in 2012
with a sixty-two percent response rate
so this chart is a little busy so let's
just look at the top line in 2002 I
start out with data and this is taken
from David Letterman's article on the
enrollment slowdown which was an Inside
Higher Education in 2002 we had 16
million college students in the United
States that increased to 20 1,000,000 or
as you see up there for 2012 20,000 968
which is a 5 million people 5 million
increase or thirty one percent the
projection for 2022 is approximately
twenty four thousand 24 million students
excuse me which is a three million
increase from 21 million in 2012 to 2022
however that's only a 13-point nine
percent increase so it's increasing
college enrollments but at a decreasing
rate the same article also said that
bachelor's degrees from the period of
2012 to 2022 will only increase
seventeen percent in comparison to the
forty five percent increase in the
decade from 2002 to 2012 what types of
online education do we have there's
web-based this is a face-to-face source
that uses a course management system
many of you in this room use it there's
a hybrid system that uses both
face-to-face and online delivery typical
for hybrid is the first course class and
the last class people teach in a live
classroom and all the classes in between
are done online online is a course that
uses online delivery and either a Moodle
or a
blackboard platform now there's a raging
debate as many of us in this room know
about online education there are those
who are for it and those who are against
it so let's take a minute and look at
the pros and the cons the pros are sixty
2.4% she he says of all surveyed
colleges offer online degree programs at
the end of 2012 the Allen and seaman
report explain that in 2003 only fifty
seven point two percent of all academic
leaders were convinced that learning
outcomes were the same or superior to
face-to-face outcomes that number in
2012 is now up to seventy seven percent
so that's a significant increase when
reviewing learning outcomes and online
courses those who believe that the
outcomes are inferior that has dropped
from a 32 point four percent in two
thousand eleven to twenty three percent
in 2012 and again highridge in online
education adults want efficiencies they
want the time flexibilities that online
education offers and it will online
education for traditional students can
actually enable them to finish their
education in three years instead of four
which means a big cost savings and also
big savings in time the cons online
retention course rates according to Zen
Netsky are on the average ten to twenty
percent lower than in face-to-face
courses and the she he said that in the
fall of two thousand twelve thirty point
two percent of all officials said that
their faculty faculty accept the value
and the legitimacy of online education
and that's up from twenty seven point
six percent from the fall of two
thousand five but that's not really a
big increase
twenty-three percent of all academic
leaders feel that the learning outcomes
in online education are still a bit
inferior to face-to-face outcomes but
the biggest one is from the Ellen and
seaman report where they said between
2007 in 2012 the barrier for faculty
accepting the legitimacy of online
education actually increased from 61.1
percent to sixty six point eight percent
challenges for students technology as we
know is always an issue do they have the
right types of software is it compatible
discipline is a challenge many academic
leaders feel that discipline is a huge
barrier for students that number has
increased from eighty percent in 2007 to
eighty eight point eight percent and
I've taught online now at three
different schools for several years and
I can honestly stand here and tell you
discipline is always an issue and at our
university because so many of us teach
online we call students we email them we
do whatever is necessary to help them be
successful but if the student is not
motivated and discipline that can be a
big problem everything is written in an
online environment and for people who
need a lot of verbal explanations and
repetition this can present some issues
or challenges challenges for the
professor's all chief academic officers
agree that too in order to deliver a
very well developed online course that
this takes much more time and effort in
two thousand six forty point seven
percent agreed that people needed more
time and more effort to deliver an
excellent online course by 2012 this
number was up to forty four point six
% and in many colleges what people
basically do is replicate their
face-to-face class in an online
environment and let me just be the first
to if you've never taught online or
written curriculum for online that is
not going to work you have to do a lot
of different things I see some smiles
out there so those of you who teach
online know what I'm talking about
technology is always a factor faculty
need to always be up-to-date on the
latest technology and we need continuous
improvement as faculty members when we
did our session in South Carolina Mary
and I told the group faculty workloads
can impact the delivery of an online
course because if you have a person
who's teaching a lot of live classes and
then you ask them to deliver many online
courses that can be an issue where are
we headed in terms of accreditation
standards today most accreditation
standards and I'm only standing here and
speaking from the Higher Learning
Commission which is the Midwest
accreditation body and at mount vernon
nazarene university we have the
Accreditation Council for collegiate
business school programs accreditation
at for every one of our business
programs at every level I a CBE many
Christian schools are accredited by them
but when four terms of in credit a shin
standards we have to review the
attendance meeting major course
objectives and required learning
outcomes not only is stated in the
syllabi but in terms of our assessments
for online degree programs what we've
done is we've standardized the syllabi
we've standardized the discussion boards
and the grading rubrics and because we
are Christian University every one of
our courses has to have a faith
integration component we have to
maintain very high curriculum standards
for all of our online courses
and the biggest thing I would want to
say to this audience is you have to make
sure that all your every single online
students know that there is going
they're going to be held accountable for
the standards and what I've done is in
all of my courses I send out a
voluminous email and i balled it I put
every single class assignment every
single week I put what the attendance
requirements are because unfortunately
in online there's sometimes you have to
fail people and most of the ones I've
had have been for attendance but there's
other times you have to fail people so
you want to make it crystal clear
upfront what the standards are and that
they are going to be held accountable
now in the future what's going to be
changing one of the big items on the
table today happens to be certifications
there was an article in The Wall Street
Journal it'll be up to about a year and
a half ago where the University of
Wisconsin when one of the big 10 schools
announced for the first time that they
are going to grant bachelor's degrees in
their adult programs for people that can
take a series of certification exams and
these are people that have some college
credits but not all and they will not
necessarily have to have the full
component of courses to get the degree
that's a first in our region of the
country but in the other regions of the
United States this is being discussed in
terms of granting degrees in the future
so just be aware and it doesn't mean
that people are going to have to take
every single course they might take a
few online courses sit for these exams
and if they can pass it they will be
given a bachelor's degree faculty need
to always participate in the technology
we need to continually be updated in
terms of our technology skills the
survival of some private colleges are
going to be impacted by the changes in
the industry and since life is about
continual change people will need to
a positive attitude when dealing with
transformational change higher education
wants to know that or I'm sorry industry
wants to know that higher education is
adequately preparing their students to
not only lead but to come up with great
entrepreneurial ideas so let me tell you
all about a real life success story that
we've had at mount vernon nazarene
university Sam no bellucci I'll tell you
about his background when Sam was born
his biological mother was 15 his
biological father was 16 in Pittsburgh
and the no bellucci family from
Johnstown Ohio adopted him he was
home-schooled until a sophomore year of
high school when he attended Johnstown
high school because he wanted to play
sports when he was a junior the family
went through a crisis and Sam told me he
wanted to get a job where he could make
a lot of money I love science I saw that
if I joined an ambulance company in
columbus ohio i could make money and
help my parents out with this crisis so
he went to Central Ohio Technical
College nights while he was a high
school student and became a registered
emergency medical technician and an
ambulance driver when he first came to
mount vernon nazarene university he was
a traditional undergraduate student and
he received a Bachelor of Science degree
in sports management in 2011 he received
a master of science and health care
administration degree I had him for two
online courses as did many people in
this room and he told me when I met him
at that time frankly I have to tell
everybody in this room I was shocked
normally you don't meet online students
and he said dr. Britt I really want to
come in your grading techniques
intrigued me so he came in I was
expecting a man in his 40s from his
postings you can imagine my shock when I
was he was a kid he was 25 years old so
we talked for two hours the first time I
met him and it was just unbelievable he
told me at that time one of his dream
to go to medical school but he said I'm
too old I said you're never too old if
God wants this it is going to be so
after he got his master of science and
health care management from mount vernon
nazarene university he had the
opportunity to become and me became the
manager of the Ohio health urgent care
clinic in New Albany and some of you in
the snow that is Lex Wexler's planned
community not only one of the richest
men in the state of Ohio but in the
United States he was the CEO of the gap
the limited abercrombie and fitch and
they told Sam they were considering him
because he had a master's degree in
health care but they were just so
intrigued how could he be that young and
done and had completed in his life what
he's done so he got that job for a year
and a half but we kept talking he kept
in touch with me and he said Margaret I
really want to go to medical school so
we prayed and I said well if you he took
his mcat exams he didn't do as well as
he wanted the first time I said go take
a prep course he did we have outstanding
fact science faculty at Melbourne and
Nazarene University and I'm not just
standing here and saying it because I
work there they have had better than a
ninety percent acceptance rate in
medical school which is for any school
phenomenal so their outstanding faculty
and I said to him you're going to have
to go back and do the makeup courses you
want to come back here so he quit his
job and he did it he retook the mcat he
got much better scores and he was
accepted into every medical program he
applied for but the one he went for was
the inaugural class of the ohio
university ohio osteopathic medical
program in double in ohio and at the end
of September he was told by the ohio
university administration he was
appointed to the committee by the
immense ered by the American College of
Graduate Medical Education that is
looking at successful combined medical
doctor and doctor of osteopathic
medicine it's an MD do program and
that's the two degrees he will get when
he grabbed
weights from Ohio health Ohio University
osteopathic program but this committee
is looking at that education across the
nation and they said the reason they
wanted him was because his background
was so unusual and he is a first-year
medical student and we still talked by
email or he called me a few weeks ago
and said it's everything he wanted so in
conclusion higher education we are going
through some major transformations in
terms of the technology survival and the
delivery modes for various types of
education we need to understand i would
encourage everybody today if your school
is not doing our online or you haven't
learned you need to learn it in order to
keep going in our industry and here are
all the references and thank you very
much
Thank You Margaret for that very helpful
overview we do have 10 minutes for
questions so I will open the floor and I
don't know that we do we have
microphones this morning excellent ok so
these ladies will help you first one
over here thank you my question is to
dr. Britt regarding an angry sorry
Margot regarding a southern New
Hampshire and liberty you showed us
statistics on their success in gaining
market share do you have any other
information or if you've seen on any
other reports on other measures of
success such as profitability or
creation of value well obviously I'm
sorry that's loud obviously you need to
graduate students because one of the
things that the United States Department
of Education is looking at now and
especially for private schools and also
for Christian schools would be how many
students graduate how successful are
they at the university of southern New
Hampshire they're actually assigned an
admissions counselor when people sign up
for online education and these people
are tracked and they have a computerized
system where if people are not online
for a long period of time they get a
call from a counselor okay now some
people can say that's there's pros and
cons of that that's good support that's
marketing one of their goals is to have
people be successful because Paul
LeBlanc who is the president of the
university of southern New Hampshire is
an immigrant to this country and his
parents worked in factories and it was
their dream for their son to go to
college and he said when he became a
college president it was a burning
desire for him personally to make sure
people were successful so if they were
going to do this big online thing and do
it quickly and save the college he said
we either do it the right way or I won't
do it at all and that's why he wanted
clay dr. clay Christiansen
from Harvard to come because he had read
his book and disruptive technologies and
felt you know we're just not going to do
online we're going to have all the
support staff and the resources that go
with it and it paid off so my question
is for Kevin I'd like to know if you
used a textbook in the power to cure
course and also what type of assignments
you gave the students thank you thanks
for the question no actually I have not
used the textbook I have that material
there and and I'm toying with the out
how to work that in there at this point
what I have them do is to watch the
weekly episode and then each week the
the description of the assignment is
pretty pretty much the same it's to
review the video compare this and
reflect on this and light of what you
read in the textbook there's actually
two textbooks I have them reading ones
actually textbook and one's a parallel
companion book so I said go back through
the video make the connections that you
can between the hill textbook and the
other book and then and write about
those but always through the through the
lens of faith for us i use it as the
faith integration assignment each week
for us what that means especially in an
online class is that one of the
discussion boards for the week is going
to be the faith integration board so
they know every week that's their
responsibility watch that video make
connections through the course but also
within the framework of a faith a
poverty cure makes that easy because in
many cases it just states to the case
right there so it makes it easy for them
to to build on it from there okay we've
cut back there
I think the only thing I remember from
my first economics course was a phrase
excess profits leads to ruin his
competition and while a over that the
product life cycle every industry goes
through a product lifecycle I think now
in online education we're in the growth
phase where almost anybody can make
money but even if online education
continues to grow eventually we'll have
it a decreasing rate but the supply of
people coming into the market is going
to be more and more which is good for
consumers but I'm wondering at what
point does online education become a
real challenge I understand why
administrators like this but at what
point is more and more people getting
into this going to compete away excess
profits well I'll start answering that
and jump in anytime please entry
barriers one of the things that I'm
thinking about I mean well I think
you're talking in terms of do you
venture saturate the market with schools
and so forth entry barriers for schools
to be able to do it well to get the
appropriate accreditation to meet the
standards of the government and other
entities that might want their hand in
this because we've seen that with
student financial aid and other agencies
that care very much about the definition
of attendance and and and and what that
what constitutes attendance my guess is
that my personal guess is the entry
barrier to start new programs is going
to get very high very soon add
excellence for any program and we all
know this schools are known by their
reputation and you either make it or you
die if you don't have excellence and
that includes online and I make it very
clear to my students that these are the
expectations this is why all of us we
call people I mean I've sat on the phone
and I always Kevin as my boss so every
once a while
say Kevin going to be extra phone
charges this month because I have to
spend a lot of time on the phone with
online students that's critical and you
can't lower your standards just because
it's online and it's like any industry
the cream rises to the top and that
isn't to say also because we talked
about this in Myrtle Beach not
everything will be online there is still
going to be areas in this industry for
traditional higher ed and even for
face-to-face classes for adults so we
have to keep that in mind it's just that
there will be fewer students as I showed
you on one of those charts the students
are going to be increasing but at a
decreasing rate and there was another
statistic last year in the Wall Street
Journal that caught my eye it said that
twenty-nine percent of all college
students now are traditional which they
defined from 18 to 24 you have many
veterans many veterans going back to
school but they're not counted in the
traditional mix so we have to keep that
in mind yeah there will be changes
question up front and then we'll go to
that one over there my question is for
Kevin maybe for Chris are there
additional costs or copyright issues
associated with embedding the videos and
Moodle yes that's a very good question
yeah and that's why I mention and Yoko
muncle and they're my pronouncing yes I
see it in writing and I see her in the
videos and anyway she worked with me
over the courses last year to work on
that distribution agreement so we do
have a legal document now in fact I've
got a copy of it in here and they agreed
on two hundred and fifty dollars as an
annual fee licensing fee if you will to
use it for the year so that's something
we'll pay every year that we use the
video yeah I only mention that I think
you are the very first license agreement
that we made so we're still testing the
market price of that but but yeah
yeah but having said that we want to
make this available and well used and
integrated so make us an offer we can't
refuse yeah that was a strange telephone
call and yoga called me one day and
basically she was asking me how much do
you think you should pay Oh in that case
yeah okay good forever over there thanks
for the presentations I had a parent
once asked me how as a faith-based
school we were any different from
Wikipedia which I thought the answer was
obvious but we aren't purveyors of
information and I explained that all
units of the University both inside and
outside the classroom are meant to
curate and cultivate kind of character
and our students not just simply
educating them so I don't ask this out
of skepticism but I simply wonder how
well can we do that online and is there
research to support that again
excellence is the key in my courses and
I've taught online at three schools they
do Harvard cases University of Virginia
Darden School of Business cases and they
do original research for my discussion
board postings because I teach primarily
masters students but I've done this even
at the bachelors level part of getting a
degree in industry for 20 years before I
went into higher ed and I was expected
to have research skills even with a
bachelor's degree so that's very
important personally and we all do this
in our school we have high curriculum
standards and it's critical that
students understand up front these are
the standards this is what you need to
do and our university makes it clear and
to be very blunt with you not everybody
makes it through our online programs
there are people who fail not just for
absentee but there's you know like
everybody else there's plagiarism issues
and they just can't cut it
financially I mean I'm sorry not
financially academically okay but we
keep in mind because the financial aid
standards are high too and you never
want to be in a position when you're in
an audit and you don't have attendance
records you don't have excellent
academic records etc the mission or
ethos of our school is to cultivate the
character of our students how well can
we do that in an online plan with a with
the faith integration are we have every
one of our courses at every level
associates bachelor's and master's we
have faith integration components and
that's critical and the point i would
add to that is again in our own
university i go back quite a ways of
mount vernon and i remember when our
traditional faculty had grave concerns
about us even doing adult education at
all let alone online that while you're
not sending them to chapel so how can
they possibly be you know being mentored
and so forth and what we we had to
convince them over a long period of time
is that we could indeed do it Sam is a
great example of that the faith
integration dust means more than put a
Bible passage in there and say you know
tell me what this verse means to you
today I mean there might be a little bit
of that here and there if you're trying
to make it a little easier at moments
but most of the courses are designed and
set up so that there is an entire book
dedicated to that to that issue or a DVD
series or whatever it would happen to be
so that it's something that's integral
to the topic so you're saying yeah you
can grapple with this you know the way
anybody else could or anybody could if
they just looked it up in Wikipedia but
I'm asking you to take it a step farther
and that's that step farther that pushes
them it's graded you're going to have
trouble getting straight A's in our
program if you can't get through the
faith integration part so we we take it
serious we make them take it serious
whether they want it or not and i will
add this one last thing we used to do
surveys on why people decided to come
into our programs in the first place and
then we serve they them at the end what
did you like best about it very rarely
would anybody say coming in the
or that they came to our program because
of faith integration but going out the
door they say that was one of the best
take away so they could possibly have
had and and we've had people also say
that it's been the faith that has
enabled them to take strong stands now
in their companies to do the right thing
morally and ethically and in the day and
age with which we live that's critical